with VI currency they just print  unquantifiable amounts of money they  just print it into worthlessness in  order for something to actually have  work there needs to be scarcity there's  no scarcity to the US dollar if you can  just print it with Bitcoin there's only  ever going to be 21 million points no  more can ever be created and that is so  important even gold doesn't even have a  hard cap there's always more that can be  mined from the ground I think there's an  asteroid in space which can make  everyone on earth a millionaire and so  there's always going to be more never  before in history have we truly seen  money which is absolutely  non-confiscatable